yesterday we have talked about how
Donald Trump increasingly is struggling
in his relationships with a number of
the people that are working directly for
him just now today I told you about how
Donald Trump is increasingly using his
personal cell phone to contact people
without chief of staff John Kelly
knowing about those calls and obviously
that's a sign to us that the
relationship between Trump and John
Kelly might not be so good and it is now
increasingly being discussed that John
Kelly might be out soon remember Kelly
is already Trump's second chief of staff
you had Reince Priebus chief of staff
number one John Kelly the elegant John
Kelly is often referred to by Donald
Trump chief of staff number two and the
rumor now is that John Kelly might be
replaced by a guy named Mick Mulvaney as
chief of staff number three Mulvaney's
the head of the White House Office of
Management and Budget
he's the interim head of the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau which is a
very scary story that we could talk
about in and of itself but not today
he's also a former congressman who
represented South Carolina and Mulvaney
admitted this week that he effectively
sold himself to the lobbyists that gave
him money when he was a congressman and
he tried to couch it they always have
some super innocent spin on this stuff
and Moe vainly tried to couch it as
listen it's nothing to worry about the
constituents of my district actually had
top priority and top access to me but he
said a couple days ago to the American
Bankers Association that quote we had a
hierarchy in office in my office in
Congress if you're a lobbyist who never
gave us money I didn't talk to you if
you're a lobbyist who gave us money I
might talk to you obviously if you push
Mulvaney he would say there was no
guarantee that if you gave me money I
would meet with you but he is saying
that if you didn't get me money I
wouldn't even consider meeting with you
and he also said again that at the top
of the hierarchy are his constituents
which of course is something that any
reasonable congressman would say whether
it's true or not
but the important thing is don't be led
astray on this thing right he's saying
what we all know this is how the system
works
it's a horrifying system lobbyists
bought access to him when he was a
congressman and you can rephrase it a
different way right the innocent way is
I would prioritize my constituents over
everybody and giving me money is no
guarantee that I would meet with you if
you're a lobbyist you could put in a
different way which is if you want to
meet with him you have to give him money
if you didn't he wouldn't even consider
meeting with you and as usual the double
standard we don't know whether he is
going to be Trump's third chief of staff
but when President Trump was candidate
Trump he said the money influence system
in Washington is a disaster he was the
populist anti cronyism anti lobbyist guy
he was going to drain the swamp and stop
the revolving door hiring a guy who
admits to selling access to run your
staff is not exactly what I would call a
draining of the swamp and I also think
it's pretty clear that Mick Mulvaney
messed up not by the selling of access
but in the eyes of the media and you
know just the general public he messed
up because he admitted to it right also
just not say this I mean this is
business as usual in politics but most
people are smart enough not to say it
well I would not at all be surprised if
we hear a defense from Trump if he does
end up getting rid of John Kelly and
hiring Mick Mulvaney of saying listen I
continue to insist that the system that
Mick Mulvaney participated in is a bad
system I participated in it because I'm
smart and I admitted during the debates
that I used the legal means available to
get politicians to do what I want but we
can't just penalize Mick Mulvaney
because he did not create the system
he's just working within it and we will
see if that is sort of defense that's
given and then as usual there was a
tweet for everything right Trump had
chief of staff number one Reince Priebus
he has chief of staff number two John
Kelly and if he brings in Mick Mulvaney
anytime soon that would be three chiefs
of staff in about a fifteen or sixteen
month period check out what President
Trump tweeted back in January of 2012
about Barack Obama's Chiefs of Staff
saying three chief of staff's by the way
it's Chiefs of Staff but I don't think
at this point we can hold trump to
kind of grammatical standard three chief
of staff's in less than three years of
being president part of the reason why
barack obama can't manage to pass his
agenda a tweet for every occasion is
there anything that Trump criticized the
Obama for that he hasn't done himself to
maybe an even greater degree and then we
also have the total implosion when it
comes to staffing and nominations of
white house dr. Ronnie Jackson who
famously said that Donald Trump is six
feet three inches tall
239 pounds and could potentially live to
be 200 years of age he improves his diet
and exercise he now is withdrawing his
name but we're gonna get to that on
tomorrow's program so just the big
picture of the chaos and the White House
story that's not going yeah quick point
here to Trump has had five
communications directors oh yeah once he
replaces hope Hicks he'll have six Obama
only had five and he was president for
eight years
whereas Trump it's been like a little
over a year now in Trump's defense
weren't some of those five like there
were the same people who had multiple
stints yeah Sean Spicer had to come back
yeah that was a nice little story hey I
think I think it's for individuals total
yeah so certainly the idea that
everything is very very calm and
operating business as usual I mean I
guess this is business as usual in the
White House which is people are senior
after six weeks if they're lucky to last
that long and the revolving door that
Trump has stopped when it comes to
lobbyists supposedly seems to have been
replaced by the revolving door of White
House staff and secretaries so we'll be
following that send me your thoughts
about Mick Mulvaney I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's episode of the
program is made possible in part by
Coins schedule which is a listing site
for cryptocurrency icos that's been
around since 2016 it was actually one of
the first websites to show helpful
listing information about icos you can
look i ce o--'s up by name industry the
end date the start date and coin
schedule gives each IC o---- a score
using an algorithm based on dozens of
parameters that help determine how
trustworthy an IC o---- is for example
whether or not the identities of the IC
o---- team have been verified whether
the IC o----
has a white paper and other factors like
those they don't try to make predictions
about the long-term success or failure
of an ICO often that's actually
impossible to do what coin schedule does
is provide users with a combined score
of how much operational risk there is
four different icos so that you can know
where to be extra careful when you see a
low rating if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link to the coin schedule
website at the top of the video
description nothing in coin schedule
should be considered personalized
investment advice icos are risky people
should do their own research and make
their own decisions